the active lifecycle is when your
activity is in the foreground and has
focus here it's actively receiving input
from user events and no other activities
are obscuring it on pause is called and
the active life time ends as soon as
your activity is partially obscured like
in this example you can see here the
permissions dialog is displayed in front
of Google Play for an app install or the
same thing happens when you have another
activity trying to fulfill an implicit
intent and the user needs to make a
selection so to make efficient use of
limited resources you'll want to use
these signals to adjust your apps
resource burden so most updates to your
UI can be paused when this life time
ends which is announced by unpause but
as you see the app is still visible so
you shouldn't pause any processes that
are drawing your UI the visible life
time on the other hand continues
whenever the app is at all visible and
ends as soon as it's completely obscured
by another app like this at this point
our app is moved to the background so
when you see on stop you know the user
can't see your app at all
so while on create a non destroyer will
be called at most once each time your
app is run these handlers are likely to
be called many times while the app is
running now this is where things get a
little different on almost all platforms
app life cycles are deterministic
generally you'll start a program and
it'll keep running until it either
completes or the user cancels it if you
look at traditional desktop development
that means your app keeps running until
your user chooses quit or exit from the
file menu at that point you can save
state and free resources but as we know
on Android life cycles work a little
differently so let's take a closer look
at exactly how that works now